um so I'll tell you about to source
extractors and resilient functions and
I'll define these so you'll know what
they mean so probably you all know how
important randomness is in computing
it's used in algorithms distributed
computing cryptography of course for
these applications you almost always
need uniform uncorrelated random bits so
there are some lower bounds that if you
want to do certain cryptographic tasks
like bit commitment or zero knowledge
even if the bits are seemingly not that
far from uniform you can't do it
and of course randomized algorithms
typically the analysis assumes perfect
randomness but natural random sources
may be defective real computers often
get their randomness from clock drift or
thermal noise or some device like a
Zener diode and weak sources arise in
other situations for example in
cryptography even if you start with some
uniformly random bits if the adversary
learns some information about your bits
then conditioned on the adversaries
information your bits are weakly random
and these defective weakly random
sources also arise in pseudo-random
generators when when you might be
conditioning on the state of some
computation so it's a very natural and
important goal to purify it will be
Granum source so now we want to model a
weak random source your first thought
might be if you haven't seen this you
might think oh well let's just use the
shine and entropy which you're probably
all familiar with this turns out not to
be ideal because the Shannon entropy
could for example place very high
probability like 99% on some fixed
string which is completely useless now
it's probably point O one its uniform on
n bits so this string has a significant
amount of entropy but you won't be able
to do much with it but with probably
0.99 it's
useless so it turns out the better
notion for this purpose is min entropy
and here this really what you're doing
is taking the largest probability and
taking the log of the reciprocal of that
so in this example the the min entropy
is is just a constant
but yeah so let's talk about Moorabbin
entropy here I'll I'll use the notation
NK source for a source Sun and bits with
min entropy at least K and what this
means is that all strings have
probability at most 2 to the minus K so
that's the way you should think about it
and a particular special case is we just
have a uniformly read we have a set of
size 2 to the K or more and we have a
uniformly random element from that set
this has been entropy K and in fact this
the the general case a general source
with min entropy K's is a convex
combination of these special sources so
it's really enough to just consider this
special source so throughout this talk a
weak sources just think of a uniformly
random element from a set of size 2 to
the K and our goal here will be to
extract randomness from from us from a
weak source so so our first so what we
would want ideally would be a
deterministic procedure to extract
randomness from any and K source we
don't want our deterministic procedure
to depend on the source we want one
fixed extractor and should work for
everything right so so our initial
formulation might be something like this
we we have some fixed deterministic
function whenever this is a weakly
random string this is a uniformly random
bit but but this is impossible
and the proof I it's not hard if we had
such an extractor well this
deterministic function maps some strings
to zero and some to one it has to map
half of them to one of these let's say
it maps at least half of them to zero
well then this is a set of size two to
the N minus one
but the extractor always maps the output
to zero so it fails for that for that
set so this is impossible this this
ultimate goal so what can we do
oh there are a few ways we could we
could try to circumvent this result one
as one is we could make some assumptions
on our weekly random source and this has
been a fruitful area we could define
special cases of such a source where
there is enough structure that we can't
achieve this and this is this is a
useful concept but now let's say we
don't want to make any assumptions on
our weak random source well one approach
is to use seeded extractors which
extract using a short with the help of a
short uniformly random string so just an
order log n bit string can help us do
this extraction but we're not going to
take that approach here here we're going
to extract using independent sources so
we're going to say well we can't extract
from one weak source let's say we have
two or maybe more independent weak
sources can we extract from these two or
more weak sources and this can be
perhaps useful in practice right if the
if in practice you want to seed your
generator it may be you you're going to
use some operating system variables as
one source and some unrelated variables
as and other source perhaps that would
be useful in practice though it's a but
it's a very natural mathematical
question and that will be the focus of
this talk
so in this talk first all I'll continue
introducing our the model and I'll tell
you about our results and then I'll tell
you some of the techniques we use and
then I'll conclude so so the focus is a
to source extractor so here we have two
independent weekly random sources 2nk
sources and we want one deterministic
function that will output the uniformly
random bit really we would want more
than one bit but let's just focus on one
bit for now so so in particular we want
the probability that the extractor
equals one to be very close to 1/2
there's a very natural matrix view of
this so I'll use capital letters to
denote two to the small letter so our
goal here will be to construct a big end
by a big end matrix so that every big K
by K big K sub matrix is balanced it has
roughly the same number of zeros as ones
so we could think of one week random
source as picking out some subset of the
rows one another week random source is
picking out a subset of the columns and
if you take a uniformly random element
from each of these two sources you get a
uniformly random element from this sub
matrix so so if it's balanced then then
the bit will be have bias it will be
close to 50/50
existentially we can do this with when k
is just about to log n big k is about to
log begin so you know these are pretty
small sub matrix sub matrices but
existentially is not what we want right
we want to be able to actually do that
we want an actual randomness extractor
so our goal will be to do this
explicitly so what can we do explicitly
so shanton foster Ronnie first asked
what we can do with explicit with two
independent sources and shramko rec
looked at our modeled more or less so so
what's been done okay so going back to
small letters again min entropy just log
in plus a constant is enough but what's
been done well sure encoder I could
observe that the classic Lindsay's lemma
says that a Hadamard matrix works for
min and should be greater than n over
two and this was the but that was the
best known for quite a while until
Borgan came along in 2005 and used to
additive combinatorics to shave off a
little bit so 49 percent 0.49 n he gave
some unspecified constant less than half
and Ron Ross also showed how to do it if
he said you don't need both sources to
have min entropy and over to but just
one one source could have min entropy
and over to the other could have min
entropy logarithmic and this was the
state-of-the-art before our work but
they're not actually because of sorry
because of the lack of success here in
getting coming close to this logarithmic
lower bound people looked at extracting
from more sources so Barak and payaso
vickersontour use a constant number of
sources to extract from any linear Inman
entropy
and then Rao showed actually midnight
should be any even into some small power
is enough and lead in several works got
got it down to just three sources with
poly logarithmic Minh entropy so this is
a very nice result it's a great result
but you know you can't view it as a
matrix anymore it's now it's a three
dimensional object so if you the two
sources sort of seems special so our
main result we succeed in building a to
source extractor for poly logarithmic
min entropy so you know this is sort of
what happened before us we got it down
to just poly logarithmic min entropy and
we could extract us one bit or maybe a
few but we showed how to build upon our
work and extract most of the entropy out
this has applications to Ramsey graphs
this so a que Ramsey graph it has no
independent set or clique of size okay
bipartite que Ramsey graph has no
bipartite K by K clique and no bipartite
K by K independent set an air addition
and maybe the first use of the
probabilistic method showed the
existence of K R at Ramsey graphs when K
is just about to login but again he we
were interested in explicit
constructions
so pictorially what we what we won here
is we want a to color all the edges say
red and green in such a way that if you
look at any two sets of size K if you
look at all the edges between them
approximately half are colored red and
approximately half are colored green
there's been a lot of work I won't go
through this you know in detail again
the Hadamard matrix gets osseous easily
disk where root n then it was a
breakthrough when Frankel and Wilson God
got it down much well below any
polynomial although it didn't work in
the bipartite setting bipartite is
harder and then some bipartite just
getting below square root n was was
interesting and then Baraka tile got
that it sub polynomial and broke it out
again got it even even lower and then
and what we do and was done
independently by Cohen is to get to to
the poly log log n ok so so we can get
Ramsey graphs bipartite Ramsey graphs
where K is 2 to the poly log log n so
those are our results now let me give
you an overview of our techniques feel
free to ask questions
so uh let me give you a couple of the
tools that we're going to use one is a
strong seeded extractor so strong
extractor so X will be the end case
source so the first end bits are from a
weekly random source and why the seed is
going to be a uniformly random string so
d think of D is much smaller than N and
a strong seeded extractor has the
property that sort of even conditioned
on the seed why the extractor output is
very close to uniform so in equivalent
way of viewing this which will be useful
for us is that is the following if we
cycle over the seeds why we get to to
the little D different functions so I'll
call that capital D right so we get we
have capital D functions F sub y so we
think of each of those is just a
function on the n bits and for any weak
random source X with min entropy at
least K most of these FY of X's will be
close to uniform for different X's will
have different of the F Y's being close
to uniform but for any X most of them
will be close to uniform so that's what
you should think of we have D D
functions and most of these are
extractors for any X and there's an
explicit construction where little D is
just logarithmic ok and don't worry
about the number of bits but just think
of little D is logarithmic so Big D is
polynomial ok so we have a polynomial
number of functions which extract most
of which extract from anything there's
been a lot of different work on this so
that's one ingredient
another ingredient is a resilient
function so this is a boolean function
with the following property so think of
an adversary as controlling some number
of the coordinates cue coordinates this
we don't want the adversary to have much
control of this function what happens is
that the remaining coordinates are
chosen uniformly at random so what we'd
like is this function to be fixed when
all of the remaining coordinates are
chosen uniformly at random then the
adversary no longer has any any power so
that's what this is it says the
probability that a function is fixed on
uniformly sampling the remaining
coordinates should be very large so the
adversaries influence is sort of Epsilon
so as an example think of majority if an
adversary controls less than square root
n of the coordinates then if the other
coordinates are chosen uniformly at
random
well you're likely to have a square root
end deviation and these end to the 0.49
adversarial bits won't are unlikely to
affect the value of this function or as
a negative example think of parity
parity is terrible from this point of
view because even if adversary h
controls just one bit the adversary has
complete control again we're thinking of
that adversary is acting last the
adversary sees what happens with all the
rest of the bits and then the adversary
can completely control the function so
this is this is what a resilient
function is you might think majority is
is the best that's that might be your
first thought but it turns out there are
better functions and we're going to use
we're going to need these better
functions okay good
right there's the constant function but
we're also going to want a balanced
function a function that's approximately
50/50 that's a good point because
actually achieving the balance isn't as
trivial as you might think
okay so let's start with a preliminary
attempt so we'll start with a strong
seeded extractor that works for some
firm in entropy K X is our n K source
and now let's look at all these D
functions that we talked about so we're
going to cycle over all values of the
seed and just think of our extractors
outputting one bit let's not worry about
that so we have these big D bits most of
them are good most of them are close to
uniform well if we have these most most
of close to uniform well maybe let's
just okay yeah the bad bits can depend
on the good bits okay
most of close to uniform let's just try
taking the majority but of course this
doesn't work I mean we can't even hope
to have a one source extractor right
but this doesn't work the uniform the
uniformly bits can be arbitrarily
correlated that's that's one reason
there are a couple of reasons this
doesn't work but that's one reason that
the uniform bits can be arbitrarily
correlated what I told you before was
assuming the uniformly bits random bits
are independent that brings us to
another tool that we're going to need
called a non malleable extractor this is
a strengthening of a strong extractor
I'm not going to define it and
completely I'll just give you a
corollary the corollary of this
definition okay so the first property is
what we saw before we have these big D
functions such that most of them are
uniform the new property is that not
only are these these a lot of the bits
uniform but those uniform bits are
actually T Y's independent almost t wise
independent okay so so now we are able
to get this long string where the good
bits are almost T wise independent G is
too small yeah what we're gonna I mean
right what we're gonna choose think of T
as poly log poly logarithmic they're
they're explicit so in a very recent
result there's this beautiful result by
dropped upon T I go Al Ahly that says we
can take the C to be just Palo
poly log polynomial and T just T squared
and n log squared n and the main entropy
can just be poly logarithmic and then
they can build these non malleable
extractors okay so this is going to be
an important tool for us so that so this
leads us to our second attempt and let's
just replace you know let's just replace
our the previous idea but now using non
malleable extractor so again we have so
this is the same thing now we're just
using our non malleable extractor in
cycling over all possible seeds okay
this is actually quasi-polynomial and no
longer polynomial but let's not worry
about that for the moment okay now we
try taking a majority well this doesn't
work either the number of bad bits is
more than square root D and again this
is not surprising this we only have one
source we can't expect to have a one
source extractor but this is but this is
our approaches related to this so the
first step of our approach is to use our
two sources to construct a string Z on a
polynomial number of bits such that
almost all of the bits are uniform and
poly log wise independent okay so we're
going to do something almost what like
what you just saw and our stand our
second step will be an explicit
extractor for this for Z and this will
be something like a resilient function
you're using two sources to construct
this Z but you said Department before
was that you had more than is Dean bad
bits right bad bits right so what's the
advantage of using the second source
okay yeah there the error is going to be
a problem if we just try to use one
source so using two sources so enables
us to get to get much better error so
let me okay so actually it might be the
next slide or two let's look at step one
okay so we're going to do what we said
before in the beginning we're going to
apply the non malleable extractor right
so if you look at so here in this in
this non malleable extractor the number
bad indices is some epsilon times D
actually it won't be you know this is
going to be too many bits for us it's
going to be bigger than D to the point
nine nine or anything but what we do
what we do now is we we're going to
sample some pseudo random subset of
these indices using the other source so
so we're going to okay let's see there's
another picture so we're gonna so T is
some pseudo random subset we're going to
do the pseudo random sampling of this
string D of this string the pseudo
random subset is done via extractors
themselves but let's put that aside for
a moment and we're just going to look at
those bits and the point now is that the
number of bad indices becomes much more
favorable to us so what why is that in
in the in the first you know if we just
use one source the fraction of bad
indices is very small but we have quite
a long string now we're able to more or
less maintain the fraction of bad of bad
bits but get a much smaller string so if
we have a much smaller string with the
same fraction of bad bits this is a much
more favorable situation that's
intuitively what's going on so that
that's that's a rough idea of what's
what's going on here but I don't want to
spend too much more time on this because
actually this this step can be achieved
in an alternate way just by slightly
modifying a construction of Li this is
you know a way to do that so I want to
spend most of the time executing the
second step so what do we have in the
second step we have this string Z the
number let's say it's of length M the
number of bad indices is like m to the
point nine nine and the good bits of Z
are poly log wise independent let's call
this distribution D and this is what we
want to extract from we want to extract
from such a string where the good bits
are poly log wise independent and the
number of bad bits is like m to the
point nine nine now we're going to
extract from this by using some sort of
function think we'll think of it as a
circuit see that we'll design explicitly
and what we're going to want is that
when we sample the good bits X we're
going to want the function to be fixed
with high probability right because the
good bits are are going to be uniformly
random and poly log wise independent
well-seasoned is enough to get what we
want we're going to want the probability
that C is not fixed that it's not fixed
to be small the probability that it's
fixed should be very high
okay so so the first so step two will
have two parts in the first part in
reality we have poly log White's
independent but now we're going to try
to assume that they're actually
uniformly random and independent not
just poly log was independent so this
this is going there two ideas that's
going to make this that are going to
make this work
the first ideas is it helps a lot if we
assume that this circuit is monotone why
would that be useful well a monotone
circuit we can easily tell whether it
whether the function is fixed after
setting all the other values right
because okay so X sets the good bits now
to see if the adversary has any control
we just need to substitute into all zero
string and the all one string for the
remaining bits if those two strings are
equal
well then every since it's a monotone
function then it doesn't matter what the
adversary does it's still fixed so it's
only going to be unfixed if if the all
zero string and they're all one string
give different values so so in that case
the probability that C is not fixed is
the probability that C of X 0 is
different than C of X 1 and we're
calling that C prime so that's that's
the first idea for this part the second
idea is to use a result of Braverman
mrs. Braverman showed in a remarkable
work that that if you have any AC 0
circuit meaning any circuit of constant
depth and polynomial size then it's
fooled by poly poly logarithmic poly log
wise independence so if we choose the
bits from a poly log whites independent
distribution D it's the same as choosing
them from a uniformly random
distribution u these probabilities will
be very close to each other
okay so these two ideas so let's let's
put these two ideas together so so if we
put them together we say that if C is
both in AC zero and monotone then the
probability that C of C is not fixed is
the probability right it's the
probability that it's not fixed when X
is chosen uniformly random the
probability when X is chosen according
to D is about the same as when it's
chosen according to you because oops
sorry because it's really just saying
we're fooling this this new circuit C
prime the circuit C prime just has depth
one more than the original circuit C so
if C was in AC zero then so is C prime
okay so it's enough to fool the circuit
C Prime and Braverman tells us that
Polliwog wives independence suffices so
so because of this we can assume that
the good bits are independent and
uniformed so our remaining task is the
following we want to come explicit
construction of a monotone function C in
AC zero on M bits such that C is
resilient even if an adversary controls
M to the point nine nine of the bits and
this function should be almost unbiased
there should be approximately 50/50 and
if we do this then we're done
but this still seems this is still a
non-trivial task we're going to
construct such a such a function or
circuit C by D randomizing I tie lineal
so let me tell you about I tie and the
Neil's work so Italian lineal gave a
probabilistic construction of a function
that's resilient to n over log squared n
bits
so again majority is resilient to like
square root n bits and if an adversary
smaller than square root n it doesn't
have much control but if it's bigger
than squared then it almost controls
majority what this is saying is it's a
it's a much better function than
majority even even if an adversary
controls you know less than n over log
squared n it still will only you have
small influence over the resulting
function so it's a bit so it's a it's a
strong result and let's look at let me
tell you what we're going to do is
modify their construction because we
can't just use their function directly
so their function is based on the
tribe's function the tribe function is
just a DNF on disjoint variables so you
could think we divide the n bits into
tribes of size about log n and if all
the members in the tribe agree then we
set the function to one if any member of
the of a tribe if any mem if in all
tribes at least one member says no we
set it to zero okay so that's why it's
called to try but it's just a DNF so
it's an aura van's of disjoint variables
and the ITAR linear function of course
the truck you know a tribe by itself is
quite bad because if an adversary just
controls all the bits of an and it can
just set all those bits to one and then
control the function so it just would
need order log n bits to control the
function the are a linear function it's
in Manhattan tribes sort of okay these
these are trying these tribes first of
all they're very randomly negated so
some of the variables in them are
negated
and the partitions are chosen randomly
and so in one partition might look like
this another partition you know the
first tribe might be here here and here
all right so these so these tribes the
partitions are quite different
the intuition being that if an adverse a
you know tries to control some some
tribe a few tribes in in in one or a few
functions it won't be able to control
all the tribes in all the functions or
at least one tribe in all the functions
that's some sort of intuition and again
this function is resilient to
coalition's of size and over log squared
n there's a couple of problems with this
function versus probabilistic so if we
just tried to deer an demise their
construction it would take exponential
time the second is that it's not
monotone I said they're random negations
so we need to fix both of these problems
so how are we going to randomize this so
the key ingredient will be to construct
these partitions in a pseudo random way
and we're going to use more partitions
actually not just n will use a
polynomial number and we're going to
want the following properties that any
small subset of of 1 through n has a
small intersection with most partitions
what does that mean it means what I mean
by that is we'll say it has a small
intersection with a partition if it has
a small intersection with any block in
that partition so for most partitions
the adversary shouldn't be able to have
significant influence over any any one
block and by a small subset I mean size
and to the point 9 9 and this is used to
bound the influence of it of the
adversary but we also need to bias and
for this we'll need the the partitions
to be sort of pairwise independent in
the sense that the intersection of any
two blocks should be bounded and this
will be used to bound the bias of the
function so these are the two properties
we're going to want
so how are we going to construct these
partitions we're going to again appeal
to extractors seeded extractors so so
we're going to look at the graph of a
seated extractor usually we think of an
extractor this way so these are going to
on the left side we put we're going to
put all the possible inputs to the weak
random source on the right side we're
going to put all possible outputs and
we're going to connect a string here to
a string here if some seed and input
this is going to come out put this so
the extractor property usually says that
if you look at a large subset here it
distributes almost randomly over here
but we're not going to look at it that
way we're going to take this alternate
view of follows we're going to we're
going to think of it this way where if
we pick any sort of test set on the
right hand side well if we have a fixed
test set here each each string here
gives us an estimate of the size of T
the estimate corresponding to this will
be the fraction of strings that land in
T so we have a bunch of estimates for
the fractional size of T the set of bad
strings will be those those strings on
the left which give too high an estimate
for T so the neighbors that the fraction
of neighbors head intersects T is
significantly more than it should by
more than epsilon and it's not hard to
show that if you have it an extractor
the number of bad strings is quite small
and this is the the view of that we're
going to need so it sort of seems
related because you know we're worried
about we're worried about strings in two
intersecting a block in too many places
and here we have something that
intersects the set T in too many places
but this doesn't look like a partition
we don't have any partition here so we
have to somehow
we have to somehow use this to build a
partition how are we going to do that
well let me show you how to let me show
you how to convert a function into a
partition so here here here here's a
function from you know 1 through B - 1
through m for east each element and 1
through B and maps to 1 maps to one
value in 1 through m so this corresponds
to a set you know 1 i1 to i2 through b
ib and and think of this as our whole
universe so this is this is N and as M
times B so think of one fixed sub set
here which corresponds to a function to
make this sub set into a partition all
we're going to do is start shifting
right I'll just add 1 to all these
values and then I'll add 2 and then add
3 etc all the way through M minus 1 so
sofa is so if we start with some subset
that corresponds to a function just si
si plus 1 si plus 2 through si plus n
minus 1 gives us a partition of that
whole space and this is how we build our
partitions from the sets
and then these and these some and these
sets correspond to extractors so so it's
a 1 and then the extractor of X so each
each each node on the left-hand side
will give us a partition because each
node on the Left will define a set as
follows one extractor of X 1 2 extractor
of X to be extractor of X B so basically
the neighbors of each node X gives us a
set gives us a function of the desired
form and this is how we this is the way
we build the partitions
so the properties we require you know we
require that for any t of this large
size it should have small intersection
with with the partitions and this is
like the extractor property so we get
this from the extractor property and the
second property says we need this sort
of pairwise independence if you if you
translate it into the setting it says
that the neighbors of some node X if you
add I and you intersect it with the
neighbors of X Prime and you add J this
shouldn't be too large may be 0.9 times
B and and that this this follows if we
use Travis ons extractor so this is
related to what we called a design
extractor it's some generalization okay
so that's so those are some of the ideas
so the analysis you know gets a little
complicated although it's not terrible
but we give a new way of analyzing aitai
lineal it's crucial in achieving
monotonicity and D randomizing and let
me just tell you the useful inequality
that comes up in our analysis called y
onsens inequality may be usually if you
say yonce and then people think you said
jensen but then you say no and I mean
Johnson so then what this says is that
let's say we start with T subsets of
some universe U and we pick each element
in the universe we choose a random set
by picking each element in the universe
with some probability P then under some
conditions if the sets are small and
they have low pairwise intersection
which is the kind of setting we have
then the probability that all the
subsets don't lie in R is approximately
the probability of the product this is a
kind of thing that we need in our
analysis will be analyzed the bias of
the function so I won't go into any more
details
let me just tell you about some
subsequent work the first Lee used our
construction to give an affine extractor
from imminent repeat just poly
logarithmic and affine extractor means
this is the case of a structured
extractor where the source is just an
affine subspace a shift of a linear
subspace we also showed how to build on
our work to get a larger output length
like 0.9 times the entropy and Raghu
gave a an explicit resilient function
that matches the aitai lineal bound and
this also helps improve the constant in
our poly logarithmic we had like 74 and
he has like 10 if you want constant
error 18 for polynomial a small error
so some open questions can we get to
negligible error right we we have
polynomially small error but for
cryptographic applications you may want
negligible error
min entropy C log n will actually for
negligible error you're going to need
bigger min entropy but from in entropy
just C log n that would be very nice
because it would give it'll give ramsey
graphs with just where poly log in by
poly log n instead of the two to the
poly log log n and maybe most
intriguingly are there more applications
of our work either the results
themselves or the techniques involved I
think there should be we already have
several and it's only been under a when
and the techniques to solve the general
obviously a number of policy Oh
so the question is about finding the
Ramsey number so I I don't think it
would be helpful in finding them offhand
because our techniques are mostly
designed towards constructing something
that we know exists not explicitly so I
don't think I don't think it would help
us establish the limits of sort of non
explicit constructions but maybe maybe
it does in some non obvious way I don't
know
once you extract poly log n beats and
you can extract almost 2 K beats right I
mean you don't have to go on into the
0.9 times K alright but the error isn't
small enough it's not a strong sorry
when you do yeah right right yeah
there's this right my question is about
gift applications to right here so you
mentioned Ramsey graphs but margin you
do you you might want to construct our
pseudo random graph say you construct
bipartite graph and you pick any subset
X and left interested while in the right
and we'd like we do for any I mean well
that's Ramsey right but actually our
construction maybe I should have made
that clear right an extractor does give
the right number right so an extractor
if you view an extractor graph
theoretically I think of the matrix view
it says exactly that if you pick a
subset X and a subset Y then you have
the right number of edges between them
yeah their return is not optimal right
but it's still pretty I mean one over
polynomial still well I guess it would
be one over poly log when you translate
it to the size of it
yes it's not optimal we could do better
so so right so improving
I think it's equivalent if I understand
your question I think it's equivalent to
just improving that error here
I think people have to keep other
questions for later